[Music]
none of us really know each other her
all screw-ups but somehow we were all in
the same place at the same time when
Billy found those coins gosh she tell
how we glow I'm blue Oh black what i
han't no look at
too cute for straw
I'm saying these trial
the answer to what is happening to you
is here you five are the Power Rangers
did I just hear you say we're Power
Rangers is this some kind of joke we're
talking to a wall I was kind of
expecting a little more so where were
you last night me and four kids found a
spaceship buried underground I'm pretty
sure I'm a superhero cool pig in that
Cup Power Rangers were a legion of
warriors you must become those
the hologram like a video game that's a
strong gas hologram on a video you were
born for this destroy everything
she is cure evil
how do you expect us to stop her
it's morphin time so we're better than
anybody ever seen do it
[Music]
it's a lot of gold
this is your destiny
this is your time
[Music]
to remind me of my screw-up you know I
don't think we're ever gonna understand
each other they're gonna come here every
Saturday just to graduate with all these
other weirdos and criminals I keep a
close watch on this heart of mine I
can't so this is where you come every
Saturday instead of practice tragic I
keep the ends out for the times I'd buy
high the restricted area
oh gosh
lady's skirt somebody should have
pointed it out wait I did
no something happened up there okay I'm
not this
[Music]
I'm strong how strong insanely strong
like we do go back I'm gonna come across
with her and then you jump please the
king
let's go no no no Kanta Jason
sorry for cake
I've killed Rangers before it's
happening
[Music]
this is Major I'm on-site mmm